markets are shifting and transforming
quicker than ever companies and
developers struggle to maintain market
speed let alone move fast enough to
create that next wave of disruption
innovation is delayed by weeks and
months of trying to configure resources
how can you bring an idea to life
quickly and not be left behind
IBM cloud virtual servers empower
developers to immediately start
developing with speed and flexibility
from small to medium to large virtual
servers of various sizes and isolation
virtual servers provided proven compute
option with maximum agility and control
catering to your workload specifications
run your workloads where they make sense
to you and provision a variety of sites
that best fit your needs ranging in CPU
memory and storage within minutes
rapidly provision images or bring your
own through an IBM designed experience
IBM offers two deployments of virtual
service tailored to fit your workload me
public virtual servers designed to
perform for a variety of workloads
require scale and flexibility and
dedicated virtual servers which are
ideal for workloads recurring isolation
and maximum control both are easily
accessible as the next wave of
innovation hits you offering flexible
pricing which allows you to only pay for
what you use and hourly or monthly
models that best fit your business
requirements virtual servers provide
baked and logging and monitoring to gain
insights into your resources virtual
servers also offer flexible storage
options of any size and allow for
dynamic resizing up or down depending on
the spirit of your data security
capabilities but the security groups are
built in and can be added to your
virtual servers based on your needs so
you can sleep assured when your
workloads and data are safe virtual
servers can also connect to your other
clouds
secure private network wherever they may
be and whatever type of cloud you have
choice of consistency and hybrid options
are vital as we need your data might be
stored in many different places
workloads and applications can be
dynamic in nature Auto scale and load
balancing help ensure your workload is
dynamic and resizes applications during
a low or peak demand times again
allowing you to spend for only what you
need virtual servers also provide
extensions into Watson API and IO key
services so that you can truly master
your business you can join the new wave
of innovation by joining IBM's cloud
start developing workloads using virtual
servers within minutes visit bluemix.net
to start innovating